the Joe Rogan experience do you think
all the PC [ __ ] and the social
justice warrior [ __ ] is going to be
tempered after we no no I think it was
tempered because the real danger I think
the real threat in the real fear
tempered it and now that that's gone
away the real fear is gonna give way to
a new level of anger because of this
level of despair people are going to be
experiencing financially over the next
few months so there's gonna be a
heightened it's almost gonna be a that
was a slingshot effect like your people
got les Conte and they're gonna get more
kunti and more self-righteous yeah more
more self-righteous more people
chastising criticizing people and on
Twitter you really see it because people
are literally forced to be at home so if
you're forced to be at home and you
don't have the discipline to stay off
Twitter and you happen to comment
something and someone comments on your
comment and then you start talking [ __ ]
to each other that's your day that you
do but you're gonna be crazy like you're
gonna be thinking about it the middle of
the night what the [ __ ] they're right
you get up to pee I'm not gonna check my
phone me check my phone [ __ ] and they
said something's pretty good you like
goddamnit now I gotta come up with
something to say back so you start
googling statistics yeah man I mean this
is what a lot of people are doing it's
making people sick or in sicker
I have almost completely avoided Twitter
other than I'll check my DMS
occasionally and occasionally I'll check
what other people have posted that I'm
friends with or that I follow I check a
little bit but I might give it I might
give it five minutes a day I deleted my
Twitter icon about a year ago and then I
just reinstalled it maybe about a week
or two ago and I'm already starting to
see like what am i doing why am I even
looking it's just getting me pissed off
it's just too many people are angry yeah
it's just too many about nonsense well
maybe it's not it's to them it's
important right it's like when you post
it it's important but when you're
dealing with whatever the [ __ ] it is a
hundred million people that are on
Twitter or more probably more that are
posting on a regular basis and then most
of what they want to say is angry most
of what they have to want to say is
negative most of its complaining it
might feel like 60% complaining
yeah so when you tune into that like
you're getting all the problems of all
these people it's just too many people
you're supposed to deal with the
problems the people that are around you
so if there's like ten people around you
and Tommy's got a problem
what's wrong with Tommy let's go talk to
Tommy it's not supposed to be ten
million people right and then there's
hundreds of thousands of Tommy's just
flooding you're [ __ ] your feed with
[ __ ] nonsense my [ __ ] girl's
lying about this and they say we can't
vote in November [ __ ] that I'd say we
sue and whoa all this craziness and it's
like you you just deal with the worst
aspects of everyone's day or everyone's
thoughts or everyone's opinions you're
just dealing with all this negativity
and so rare that and it is really a very
much appreciated when you do find it
like a really well structured
conversation or disagreement about
something where people don't get shitty
at all like wow that's beautiful that's
pleasant to see or there's people who
want to Doc's people cuz you know they
you know they don't like this politician
that they support or they don't like
they want you to not have to wear a mask
could be one of Doc's you like there's
there's so many people that are so
[ __ ] angry and weird online and then
you add this pandemic to it and you just
got this boiling pot of shitty thinking
and anger and meanness just means
there's a lot of that where's the love
where's the love where's the camaraderie
where's the hugs isn't that the best
part of your day when you rather be
friends with people like I know you can
have disagreements and not be shitty
it's possible and that's what I loved
about the comedy stores people that you
know didn't disagree but they [ __ ]
you know there's still the camaraderie
and they're there at the end of the day
they're in the same boat like they love
you pretty much and yeah there's just
there's a lack of conservative comedians
I would say if there's anything that's
odd yeah that is I can catch that's a
very true there's a few you know that
you know of but it's pretty it's pretty
rare I think there's probably more than
we know that they're just just not
onstage they're there they're avoiding
it maybe yeah maybe um in acting it's
like [ __ ] 99% crazy yeah
makes me think that can't be real it
makes me think that it's probably a lot
of his people shaping their opinions so
that they're more accepted and loved by
the community that's right Excel and
generally all business actions
[Applause]